e o que tava me incentivando o nome dele
é Marco Antônio meu é Rose então Roma
virada ao contrário dava amor então
automaticamente virou amor para todos os
lados e a gente lançou o projeto vão
amor que foi com crianças e depois
começou a surgir várias demandas e ele
foi crescendo com isso nós nos
inscrevemos ao gente que faz que é um
programa que tem pessoa do bem que tem
aqui na Newton Paiva passando esse
pessoa do bem nós lá na Silva Lobo fomos
o projeto Roma amou teve destaque foi
premiado O primeiro é na Silva Lobo Como
projeto romamor foi
o medo e isso me deu mais força para
continuar a busca de estar falando
porque nos projetos sociais que fazer a
gente tem 32 ações que a gente já fez
com 4.100 pessoas que a gente atingiu
Então você sempre eu tinha que ir falar
né porque proativo eu já sou mas assim É
fala eu precisava falar então isso a
universidade foi me ajudando e eu fui
continuando a busca e o projeto arrumar
amor também hoje né que a gente já está
com vários profissionais tanto da
Psicologia nutrição fisioterapia todos
esses profissionais eles hoje estão
trabalhando online e voluntário por quê
Porque na época da pandemia eu fiquei
pensando gente o projeto Roma amor ele
não pode ir para rua com as ações
sociais e aí a gente fez o fica em casa
em defesa da vida que é o projeto que
a campanha fique em casa em defesa da
vida onde tem vários profissionais da
área da saúde atendendo voluntário e
gratuitamente
E com isso começamos a ver que tava
faltando profissionais da psiquiatria
porque foi uma área que foi mais afetada
nessa época da pandemia que foi a saúde
mental e não tinha a gente tinha
simplesmente um psiquiatra com isso o
que que nós fizemos falando gente temos
que buscar outras soluções e eu já tinha
uma empresa que era Verena promoções e
tinha engavetado um projeto que se
chamava a s.o.s. psiquê e tinha feito
uma marca né Fiz uma marca que chamava
ilumina a mente registrei essa marca e
busquei falei gente eu vou buscar
parceiros para poder tá ajudando o
projeto rumo amor e aí eu consegui um
parceiro que é da assistência de seguros
da gente fugiu o nó
é o nome da empresa que fez parceria com
a gente credit credit card credit card
né
eu esqueci o nome dela então nós fizemos
uma parceria com ele porque ele tem
vários profissionais na área da saúde e
ele tinha multi psiquiatras então com
isso a gente fez a iluminar a mente a
plataforma iluminar a mente ela tem
vários profissionais na área da saúde e
que são psicólogo psiquiatra e ele tem
profissionais da área da saúde total e
com isso a gente fez a plataforma
inumeramente com preço social então a
gente conseguiu fazer a plataforma
iluminar a mente com preço social então
uma das coisas que eu falo é o seguinte
tudo que você quer fazer na vida você
faça esse você tem medo vai com medo
mesmo porque porque na no caso no meu
caso que tudo começou por causa da forma
de falar e se a gente às vezes pode
atirar pode fazer alguma coisa mas não
deixei de fazer
tu tá com medo mesmo quando eu entrei na
faculdade eu tinha um propósito a minha
vida era outra hoje não hoje eu já estou
no caminho que eu mais gosto que é a
parte da saúde né E todos os alunos da
faculdade eu dou essa dica aproveitem
tudo que vocês possam aproveitar dentro
da faculdade se tem uma chance vá se
você tem um sonho vá se você tem medo de
falar se você tem esse medo pare né
entre vá mesmo com medo sabe Então é
isso que eu tenho para falar para vocês
realize os seus sonhos não tenho medo de
mudar mude
e vá com todo esse medo mas vá é isso
que eu posso deixar para vocês e eu
quero agradecer essa oportunidade tá
aqui falando no Tex que é essa
ferramenta maravilhosa que existe no
mundo inteiro já conheço o tex mundial e
conheço também o tex aqui da Newton
quero agradecer a vocês e deixar esse
meu depoimento para que sirva para vocês
faça a gente mesmo que estejam com medo
com medo mesmo com medo vá Obrigado a
todos